depuis quelques années je travaille sur
plusieurs projets où le son et l'image
sont questionnés alors cela peut être
autant des clips vidéo que des
installations interactives par exemple
est souvent la direction de création a
été d'aller du son vers l'image une
façon d'illustrer le son par l'image ou
de le matérialiser visuellement le
projet vous vous présenter il est né
d'une envie aussi de bouleverser ce
schéma là c'est à dire de fonctionner
dans l'autre sens pourquoi ne pas
manipuler l'image pour générer du son
j'ai exprimé aussi l'envi de manipuler
en direct et de me créer mon propre
outil afin de performer ou de jouer
c'est pour cela je vous présente
aujourd'hui culbuto alors qu plutôt
pourquoi ce nom c'est évidemment une
référence à se jouer ça vous rappelle
peut-être quelque chose
ce petit jouet qui utilisent ce
phénomène de balancement et qui par
extension propose une forme de deux
séquences rythmiques qui peut être
croissantes ou décroissante et c'est ce
paramètre là précisément ce paramètre
physique a motivé le fonctionnement de
cet outil ce principe là peut aussi
faire référence de façon plus pointue au
domaine de l'oscillation également mon
souhait en créant ce projet il a été
d'établir une certaine compréhension
entre le public
le dispositif est le musicien ou
l'opérateur culbuto il a été conçu pour
donner à voir le processus musicale live
le public se retrouve en quelque sorte
en face d'une partition graphique en
temps réel
c'est grâce aux interactions visuel qui
vont être sur l'écran que l'on peut
entendre un résultat sonore c'est
vraiment dans ces directions que ça
fonctionne de l'image vers le son et le
but encore une fois de ce dispositif
c'est d'établir une proximité avec le
spectateur car le spectateur va se
retrouver la foi dans un temps de
visualisation et un temps d'écouté
avant de vous proposer une démonstration
du dispositif j'aimerais insister sur la
notion d'improvisation
ça vient alors voilà l'improvisation
fait partie intégrante du projet et cela
vient du fait que chaque élément qui
sont sur l'écran agi de façon
indépendante
il n'y a aucun thème pour général qui ne
vient régir la performance donc les
modules graphique
ils sont jamais synchronisée et ce qui
confère aussi l'aspect unique à la
performance et en même temps instable
vous allez pouvoir voir qu'il ya une
esthétique de l'aléatoire qui est
développée aussi avec ce projet je vais
pouvoir faire une petite démonstration
de chaque élément afin de comprendre le
fonction de cet outil vous avez su 7 sur
cette partie des pot'arts qui me
permettent de donner une cadence à
chaque élément
y'en a rapidement une dimension
polyphonique qui se crée je l'aï éteint
mais également une dimension aussi
politique
voilà pour le fonctionnement maintenant
je vais vous proposer une démonstration
de cet outil de ce dispositif de cet
instrument
alors voilà ce projet il évidemment ce
projet il évidemment pas clos
l'interface pris une toute autre mise en
forme tout autre architecture certains
éléments graphiques peuvent être étoffée
substituer le contenu sonore aussi j'ai
construit cette interface de façon à
pouvoir rapidement changer une banque de
sons qui fonctionnent en arrière-plan
il serait intéressant également de faire
jouer deux ou plusieurs culbuto ensemble
et j'espère vous donner rendez vous la
prochaine fois peut-être avec le culbuto
orchestra